you need to stand up for yourself
because it's not a war at the end of the
day but it's like do what's right for
you Cara Delevigne just wants everyone
to leave her ex Ashley Benson alone the
27 year old model who split from the
Pretty Little Liars actress earlier this
month tooked her insta story on thursday
to defend ashe after she was spotted out
with rapper gez she wrote quote it's
more important now than ever to spread
love not hate to everyone hating on
Ashley Benson please stop you don't know
the truth only her and I do and that's
exactly how it should be
you tell him Cara I'm a little short the
spring breakers star was spotted with
gez earlier this week getting takeout
from the Apple pan restaurant in LA and
she seemingly implied they're just pals
liking a comment from a fan account
which read can't Ashley have friends now
stop saying Ashley cheated or even Cara
they just need friends right now more
than ever
earlier this month according to multiple
reports Cara and Ashley split after two
years of dating
they were pretty private about their
love but Cara did confirm their romance
in 2019 while accepting The Trevor
Project hero award I also have a very
another special woman in this room to
thank and you know who you are just in
case you aren't getting the hint she's
talking about Ashley okay continue she's
one of the people that helped me love
myself when I needed it most and I
really needed it she showed me what real
love is and show me how to accept it
which was a lot harder than I thought
and Ashe was right there to support Cara
at the premiere of her show carnival row
how proud are you showing this project
to your family your friends the the
important people in your life and what
are their reactions I don't know I'm
terrified I have the most scared I've
ever been so she's got to be cheering
you on yeah
yeah
[Music]